l'émission qui revient sur l'actualité
économique locale on commence tout de
suite avec les titres les chiffres du
chômage sont tombés hier dans les
Yvelines ils ont faiblement diminué -
0,2% plus de détails dans un instant
nous dresserons le bilan de l'opération
gaz moins cher ensemble avec l'UFC Que
Choisir elle a permis à 2597 yvelinois
de diminuer leurs factures de gaz nous
ne vous emmènerons au salon de
l'agriculture concours d'animaux
dégustation de produits régionaux nous
ferons le tour avec des producteurs et
agriculteurs et puis nous retrouverons
Geneviève Bell elle ne pouvait pas être
présente avec nous sur ce plateau nous
sommes allés la retrouver au Conseil
économique et social vous allez le
découvrir un n'est pas active qu'au sein
du syndicat patronal la CGPME à quelques
jours du 8 mars et de la journée de la
femme nous parlerons de sa nouvelle
étude sur les femmes éloignées du marché
du travail mais avant cela place aux
informations économiques de la semaine
dans les Yvelines le nombre de chômeurs
a un peu diminué - 2 - 0,2% pardon on en
est d'ombre aujourd'hui 590 dans le
département on sait que le taux de
chômage dans les Yvelines est plus
faible que dans le reste de l'hexagone
mais de ville yvelinoise saute
particulièrement du Lot elles affichent
une très bonne santé en termes d'emploi
ou dans détient le record du plus faible
taux de chômage français
5,2% et plaisir celui de la ville ou le
chômage a le moins augmenté au cours des
cinq dernières années on continue avec
du positif puisque la SNCF annonce une
vaste opération de recrutement elle veut
moderniser le réseau d'Île-de-France 900
postes sont à pourvoir les chantiers
devraient plus que doublés un forum sera
organisé la semaine prochaine les quatre
et cinq mars à Paris trois métiers sont
demandés opérateurs d'installation
Télécom de signalisation électrique et
de caténaire si vous êtes intéressé vous
pouvez poster votre candidature sur le
site qui s'affiche à cet écran
à l'appel de la CGT des salariés de
mobilité une société de transport en
commun basé à Trappes à entamer une
entamera pardon une grève à partir de ce
soir 23h30 le service des bus devrait
être fortement perturbé les grévistes
représentées 30% des chômeurs les
salariés réclament de meilleurs
conditions de travail il dénonce la
précarité de nombreux contrats une mise
sous pression des licenciements
disciplinaires de plus en plus nombreux
et un gel des salaires cette entreprise
filiale de la RATP travaille pour le
STIF et des collectivités je vous
propose d'écouter le revendication des
grévistes
de base c'est à dire nous demandons 150
euros net sur le salaire de base des
primes de nuit et un changement de
planning pour une ligne de nuit qui
tourne à c'est à dire à 6 6 nuits par
conducteur sur le planning sur la
semaine ils ont signé d'affilée ou
travail et c'est trop pour
l'UFC Que Choisir lancer en octobre
dernier une opération gaz moins cher
ensemble la société belge Lampiris avait
répondu à son appel d'offres en
proposant des coûts inférieurs à 13% au
tarif réglementé dans les Yvelines de
nombreuses personnes se sont inscrites
et
2597 ont accepté l'offre personnalisée
qui leur a été proposé en moyenne les
bénéficiaires économiseraient 235 euros
par an on écoute l'UFC Que Choisir à ce
propos
les distributeurs de gaz
voyez pas trop cette opération c'est la
première fois que ça se faisait en
France donc un certain scepticisme nous
on y croyait fortement et donc on a eu
raison parce que vous voyez bien le
résultat comme pour une première
opération c'est vraiment un excellent
résultat
on passe maintenant à l'entretien nous
allons parler de la place des femmes sur
le marché du travail pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent notre invité Geneviève Bell
ne pouvait être avec nous sur ce plateau
nous avons donc enregistré il y a
quelques jours cette interview que je
vous propose de découvrir ensemble
nous sommes jusqu'au 2 mars le salon de
l'agriculture de nous sommes ici à Paris
devant le 16e le Conseil économique
social et environnemental nous allons y
retrouver une figure locale des Yvelines
Geneviève Bell bonjour on vous connaît
dans le département des Yvelines plutôt
comme la présidente la CGPME et vous
avez d'autres fonctions et notamment
celui de présidente de la délégation au
droit des femmes et à l'égalité aussi
eux oui donc j'ai été nommée au Conseil
économique par la CGPME puisque vous
savez que chaque syndicat patronal ou
salariés à des postes aux conseillers
économique et représente justement toute
la vie publique et donc j'ai eu la
chance d'être nommé donc par la CGPME
donc la première mandature j'étais sur
l'environnement et la deuxième mandature
on m'a positionné plus sur tout ce qui
est éducation donc c'est ma section et
puis sur la délégation droit des femmes
en rencontre aujourd'hui pour deux
actualités la première c'est la sortie
de l'étude sur les femmes et l'urognées
du marché du travail mise en place par
Madame Fauvel que dit cette étude
effectivement donc on a fait cette étude
à la demande de Najat Vall sur les
femmes éloignées du monde du travail il
y avait pas eu d'études de fait jusqu'à
présent sur ce sujet on aille chercher à
comprendre quels sont les femmes qui se
retirent du monde du travail on
s'aperçoit que sont celles qui sont le
moins diplômés donc il y a une histoire
de diplôme il y a une histoire d'autres
parts de composition de la famille c'est
à dire que des femmes qui ont par
exemple un enfant vont pas s'arrêter de
travailler au deuxième enfant on tombe
déjà un peu plus bas et au troisième
enfant on est à 43% des femmes qui
continuent à travailler donc et il y a
le troisième point si vous voulez c'est
la conciliation la possibilité de
conciliation entre vie professionnelle
vie familiale et moi je rajouterais les
personnel parce que ça compte aussi
voilà et donc c'est ces trois points là
qui font que des femmes vont se retirer
du monde du travail alors avec les
conséquences qu'on connaît c'est-à-dire
des différences de salaire parce qu'on a
des accros dans le déroulé de carrière
et puis on peut rappeler que les femmes
gagnent en moyenne 25% alors 25%
un changement de mentalité si vous
voulez je pense que ce qu'il faut
vraiment changer ce sont les mentalités
les textes on les arabes on a tous les
textes qu'il faut donc ce qu'il faut
c'est un changement de mentalité alors
en tant que chef d'entreprise également
est-ce que les entreprises ont un rôle
aussi bien sûr les entreprises ont un
rôle donc à la CGPME j'ai créé une
charte ou les adhérents de la CGPME
peuvent mettre une estampille sur leur
papier à lettres etc quand ils vont
répondre à plusieurs critères sur
l'égalité salariale sur la mise en place
de formation etc etc donc là c'est en
trajet ça y est je l'ai fait c'est mis
en place et donc là maintenant ça va
être à la disposition des entreprises ce
que je cherche c'est même en tant que
chef d'entreprise à faire changer les
mentalités et valoriser ces changements
alors que peut changer finalement le
conseiller économique nos études vont
partir
grossir un petit peu là je vais dire je
vais dire la bibliothèque
personnelle
de ces personnes en charge des lois
voilà donc des fois on n'a rien qui sort
pendant un certain temps puis
brusquement bout de deux ans trois ans
on se dit tiens mais ça c'est ce qu'on a
écrit vous voyez donc c'est jamais perdu
c'est jamais perdu on a toujours
toujours une influence sur le
gouvernement et sur le sur la position
les positions les façons de voir alors
votre travail précisé vous a également
donné une idée assez originale le
trophée national sur l'entrepreneuriat
au féminin et ça c'est une longue
histoire
effectivement donc si vous voulez la
première étude que j'avais faite au
Conseil économique dans l'enseignement
nature c'était l'entrepreneuriat au
féminin en France et donc après avoir
étudié bon le système aux États-Unis au
Canada dans les pays européens etc
j'avais sorti un bon pavé sur
l'entrepreneuriat et puis j'ai eu
beaucoup de félicitations mais rien du
tout derrière rien ne bougeait donc
j'avais été voir le président de la
CGPME donc j'étais présidentE et il m'a
dit tu fais ce que tu veux bien sûr il
n'y a pas de problème parce que il faut
aussi vous voulez qu'on fasse bouger en
fait le taux d'entreprise tenues par des
femmes à l'heure actuelle on est entre
28 et 30% selon qu'on compte ou pas les
auto-entrepreneurs et il faut qu'on
arrive comme aux États-Unis un taux de
48 % des études je vous dis elle était
restée donc moi j'ai fait j'ai monté des
clubs entrepreneuriat au féminin à
travers la France on en a plus de 70 à
l'heure actuelle ce qui est énorme et
donc on a eu des actions on avait repris
les préconisations qui avaient dans mon
étude et on avait fait un livre blanc
qu'on a distribué en fait enfin qu'on a
au gentiment envoyé aux candidat à la
présence de la République bon le plan
qui est sorti sur l'entrepreneuriat au
féminin reprend une grande grande partie
des points de l'étude voilà et cette
année j'ai voulu avec quelques femmes
faire une action commune à tous les
départements et on s'est dit qu'on
allait lancer un grand trophée alors un
grand trophée sur l'entrepreneuriat au
féminin qui va voilà vous avez la
primeur qui va se dérouler sur le 18
juin donc c'est pas parce que c'est le
18 juin mais c'est parce que le
lendemain c'est la journée Planète PME
qui est la grande journée de la CGPME et
ça permettait tout simplement au
département au personnels travaillant
aux femmes des départements de monter la
veille sans frais supplémentaire
de fédérer tous mes groupes et de
valoriser le les femmes chefs
d'entreprise valoriser les femmes chefs
d'entreprise montrer des rôles de femmes
qui ont réussi et encourager les autres
à venir nous rejoindre très bien merci
beaucoup et rendez-vous du coup le 18
juin merci
cette semaine notre dossier de la
semaine vous emmène au Salon de
l'Agriculture pour en découvrir ces
nombreuses facettes avec bien entendu
les acteurs yvelinois présents un
reportage réalisé avec Jonathan wilmann
et le di-moine et Romain russeini
jusqu'au 2 mars le Salon de
l'Agriculture devrait accueillir près de
700 000 visiteurs venus de toute la
France un rendez-vous incontournable où
chaque région tente de valoriser son
patrimoine agricole et le département
des Yvelines adéquat se défendre avec
pas moins de 1300 exploitations et 43%
du territoire occupé par des terres
agricoles nous vous proposons de plonger
dans l'univers du salon et d'aller à la
rencontre des éleveurs agriculteurs et
producteurs et Vinois
le salon de l'agriculture c'est tout
d'abord près de 4000 animaux présents
des vaches aux chevaux au pavillon au
vin on y croise les célèbres moutons
mérinos de Rambouillet importer
d'Espagne au XVIIIe siècle par Louis XVI
il en existe plus qu'un troupeau à la
Bergerie Nationale leur petit plus la
qualité de leur laine et dans ce domaine
leurs éleveurs sont des experts nous
intervenons sur tous les concours de
race où il y a des boutons en LED et aux
participants donc au jugement des
toisons
dans les concours spéciaux de race
aujourd'hui Antoine est chargé de noter
des charmoises une race du Centre-Ouest
on juge sur le visuel mais surtout sur
le tactile
le concours des animaux a été créé en
1864 et chaque année plus de 1200
éleveurs tentent leur chance pour les
éleveurs des animaux
commercial puisque pour vendre ensuite
des reproducteurs
issus de la champion d'une championne de
Paris c'est un élément de promotion et
un bon nombre d'éleveurs pour qui le
salon de Paris ce sont les seuls et
uniques vacances quoi et de récompense à
Paris c'est un aboutissement pour une
vie d'un éleveur tous ces animaux bien
loin de leur ferme demandent une énorme
logistique dans le pavillon annexe par
exemple on retrouve des centaines de
vaches et pendant le salon il faut
continuer à les traire c'est là
qu'intervient Olivier son équipe il
travaille pour l'entreprise de Laval une
entreprise yvelinoise basée à Élancourt
et qui vend du matériel de traite
250 vaches à très par jour donc c'est
une grosse organisation ça nécessite
d'être près le matin le soir la nuit
puisqu'on trait des fois jusqu'à trois
heures du matin l'éveil de compo donc
c'est une grosse grosse activité mais
c'est un bon partenariat et c'est
vraiment une activité sympathique pour
nous aussi et pour l'ensemble des
éleveurs le lait récolté et testé il
passe par un système de pression dans
cette salle annexe le contenu de ses
cuves sera revendu le salon c'est vrai
que pour chaque élevox c'est un
investissement parce que faut venir vous
s'occuper de l'animal et pendant ce
temps il y a le troupeau qui reste sur
la ferme localement donc c'est vrai que
pour les éleveurs c'est une passion mais
c'est aussi un goût investissement et
c'est pour ça que le salon aussi finance
le lait produit je comprenais à peu près
45 tonnes de lait là sur les 10 jours
donc c'est pas c'est comme on dit c'est
pas une paille quoi s'occuper des
animaux du salon c'est aussi les nourrir
chaque jour là encore une entreprise
yvelinoise a remporté le contrat la
ferme de Viltain basée à Jouy-en-Josas
fournit de l'ensiage de maïs la culture
de céréales n'est pas la seule activité
de cette ferme elle élève également des
vaches laitières
de ses deux veaux
de lait tous les jours les vaches de
vilain et il y en a trois millilitres
qui est vendu sous forme différentes
sortes sous forme de fromage blanc de
faisselle bien sûr maintenant et puis
de les faire monter aussi il profite du
salon pour faire connaître ses produits
cette année en plus de la vente aux
particuliers restaurants et entreprises
la ferme s'est ouverte à la grande
distribution ça fait celle sera en vente
dans les magasins d'une grande enseigne
située à 160 km à la ronde le local un
atout vente qui prend de l'ampleur
chaque année et c'est là-dessus que mise
les producteurs des Yvelines dans le
pavillon des produits régionaux le stand
de l'Île-de-France a pour slogan
mangeons local Thierry par exemple
propose des macarons à base de produits
locaux
de grignons pour le beurre des choses
comme ça tout ce qui est macarons fruité
on essaye de on a un producteur de
fruits aux alouettes pour tout ce qui
est fruits rouges voilà quand on peut
faire local autant que faire ce peu on
fait avec voilà c'est c'est la priorité
on va dire une priorité pour l'ensemble
des exposants mais également une
priorité politique avec le serviac est
notre comité de promotion des produits
on encourage on donne des moyens en
fonctionnement en investissement et le
résultat c'est que chaque année on a
davantage de stands ici et que on est
devenu un des plus grands stands du
salon de l'agriculture alors qu'on est
la région parisienne et c'est le
paradoxe mais on est en train de
profiter de cette mode importante du
manger local c'est bien le serviat qui
est à l'initiative de ce stand une
association regroupant la région
Île-de-France les et les industries
alimentaires le but valoriser
l'agriculture régionale c'est elle qui
est à l'origine de la belle comme
produit d'Île-de-France et elle fédère
de plus en plus d'exploitants vous savez
au début il y a quelques années il
fallait se mettre à genoux pour leur
demander de venir
quelque part ici croyez pas et
aujourd'hui on sent que c'est porteurs
la ferme de Gally est ainsi devenue une
habituée du salon elle en profite pour
faire découvrir ses produits comme ces
soupes de légumes leur fabrication ne se
fait pas dans les Yvelines à Rungis où
elle achète la matière première auprès
d'agriculteurs de la région une fois
encore ont mis sur le marché du local et
du tout naturel et ça marche il s'en est
vendu en 2013 près de 11000 bouteilles
on est vraiment sur du bouillon de
légumes infusés ensuite des légumes
frais épluchés à la main de façon aussi
à contrôler la qualité des légumes
ensuite tout est mis dans la marmite que
vous avez vu la grosse marmite là et
ensuite on tout simplement et on rajoute
sel épices crème au beurre en fonction
des recettes un petit peu de maïzena
pour donner de l'ongletosité mais après
on s'arrête là la fabrication est prise
en charge par l'association andest plus
connue pour le ramassage d'invendu et
leur distribution auprès d'associations
les salariés y sont formés pour se
réinsérer sur le marché du travail il
sort de cet atelier près de 800
bouteilles par semaine mes preuves que
l'agriculture yvelinoise doit encore se
développer le servia soutien
financièrement les 200 entreprises
agrées mangeons locales en Île-de-France
retour au salon le servia finance par
exemple les stands des exposants à
hauteur de 50%. la ferme de Grignan
spécialisée dans la fabrication des
yaourts ne paye que 1400 euros
participez au salon de l'agriculture
c'est un vrai engagement en termes de
budget de communication et voilà c'est
la crise pour tout le monde donc les
budgets communication c'est forcément
généralement la première chose sur
laquelle on avoir tendance à renier car
le stand n’est pas la seule dépense pour
la ferme cette année encore elle
participe au concours général agricole
un prestigieux concours qui a un coût
118 euros de frais de dossier et 114
euros par produit présenté quelques
jours avant le salon nous étions allé
voir comment se fabriquer les 5 yaourts
que la ferme présente au concours ici
tout est artisanal des produits naturels
et un temps de chauffage au bain-marie
qu'on va dire tu prends du temps certes
mais qui rend le yaourt meilleur quoi
l'industriel les yaourts sont
conditionnés puis reposent en salle de
chauffe 5 heures c'est encore à la main
qu'on vérifie la bonne prise du yaourt
et on regarde s'il y a du sérum dessus
donc là on voit qu'il est pris dans la
chambre froide nous découvrons les
yaourts qui espèrent recevoir une
médaille cette année fait celle à yaourt
au lait entier goût poire framboise ou
pomme cannelle le vent en général
suivent derrière après une médaille au
moins sur les quelques mois après ouais
ça dépend du qualité des produits mais
en général comme les faisselle là ça
fait 4 ans qu'on a la médaille d'argent
on essaye on espère vivement d'avoir la
médaille d'or mais c'est vrai qu'on a
beaucoup augmenté notre volume en deux
ans en deux ans de production on l'a
doublé un autre producteur yvelinois
tentera aussi d'obtenir une médaille
lors de ce concours des produits
laitiers la ferme de la Tremblay cette
année elle n'a pas pris de stand au
salon de l'agriculture mais nous
retrouvons Laurent sont directeur
commercial au salon du fromage à
quelques pas de là les trois produits
présentés les voilà un fromage de chèvre
persillées un brie et un camembert
fermier fermier car dans cette ferme
tout est produit de A à Z le lait
utilisé provient des élèvent sans vaches
et 600 chèvres et pour les nourrir la
ferme cultive elle-même ses céréales
cela fait 5 ans qu'il participe au
concours et pour Laurent gagné des
médailles et toujours une consécration
pour nous ça permet déjà de voir la
qualité de notre travail mais quand je
dis la qualité c'est toute l'équipe
c'est la qualité déjà de ceux qui
s'occupent des animaux de ceux qui
fassent en fabrication qui conçoivent
les produits de les de la renommée
derrière de la régularité et surtout
c'est la plus grande récompense qu'on
puisse avoir misery sur lequel le persil
vu le succès qui rencontre je
j'ai confiance en Lui
lundi matin c'est le jour de vérité le
jour du concours général agricole des
produits laitiers près de 1000 jurés ont
été mobilisés tous volontaires et
bénévoles des professionnels mais aussi
des restaurateurs ou encore des
blogueurs culinaires à leur arrivée on
leur attribue une table ils y découvrent
alors les produits qu'ils vont devoir
juger un coup de poker
on est plutôt sur des productions un peu
industriels quand même
mais après je serai à table d'à côté je
serais très heureux aucune possibilité
de connaître la destination des produits
nous ne serons donc pas où se trouvent
les fromages de la ferme de la Tremblay
et les yaourts de celle de grignons
peut-être sur la table d'Alain on le
sent le fruit quand même
c'est des vrais fruits et
la consistance c'est plutôt bonne
produit intéressant les jurés jugent
selon trois critères le visuel la
texture et le goût et l'odeur la charte
est définie par le ministère de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation Jacky
un enseignant à la retraite participe
depuis 13 ans concours général agricole
le ciag comme il l'appelle son rôle est
guidé les jurés et leur expliquer la
démarche à suivre tu désigne un
président ou une présidente à la table
et c'est LUI ou ELLE qui fait la
synthèse de tous ces membres à la fin
pour mettre des observations
pertinentes les plus pertinentes
possibles sur chaque produit et en
particulier les produits qui n'ont pas
de médaille parce que c'est cela que les
producteurs qu'il faut renseigner pour
qu'il puisse améliorer le produit et
puis autrement bon je leur dis également
que le CGA ne souhaite pas qu'il y ait
trop de médailles une inflation il faut
qu'il y ait au maximum 30% de médailles
par rapport au nombre de produits qui
est sur la table une consécration qui
n'est donc pas facile à obtenir sur ces
tables on juge les fromages à pâte dure
comme ici le Cantal on cherche surtout
un côté bien équilibré et qui donne
envie d'en remanger le concours touche à
sa fin à la table d'Alain le président
fait la synthèse des différentes notes
attribuées tout le monde ici est
d'accord trois produits sortent du lot
les trois seront médaillés de médaille
d'argent et même une médaille d'or c'est
un yaourt à la framboise
mais il avait beaucoup de douceur au
niveau de l'aspect l'aspect yaourt et
puis le parfum framboise était quand
même très très subtil quoi donc du coup
c'est celui-là qui a emporté on va dire
la
palme peut-être un des yaourts de la
ferme de Grignon 18h lors des résultats
officiels nous retrouvons Sandy à son
stand elle vient tout juste d'apprendre
le verdict médaille d'argent pour le
yaourt entier et le yaourt à la poire et
médaille de bronze pour la ficelle un
peu déçu évidemment pour la framboise et
puis la pomme cannelle
maintenant hyper content pour la poire
parce que c'est la première année qu'on
la présentait donc du coup on est
content et puis content aussi de garder
nos médailles quelles qu'elles soient
sur sur le lait entier et sur la
faisselle ouais la ferme est de grignons
n'a pas à rougir tout comme la ferme de
la Tremblay qui voit ses trois produits
récompensés médaille de bronze pour le
brie d'argent pour le fromage de chèvre
et d'or pour le camembert de quoi
booster les ventes et accentuer la
renommée des agriculteurs Yvelines
et on finit avec l'agenda vous pourrez
assister à une journée d'information sur
la formation en alternance mardi
prochain de 14h à 17h si vous êtes
intéressé par ce mode d'enseignement ou
que vous cherchez des informations aller
à la Cité des Métiers à Trappes et le 5
mars les rendez-vous de la Maison de
l'Entreprise vous propose d'en apprendre
un peu plus sur la création en
auto-entreprise de 9h30 à midi au
programme définir son projet choisir son
statut et gérer son auto-entreprise
attention il faut s'inscrire à la maison
d'entreprise voilà c'est la fin de ce
fileto merci d'avoir été avec nous je
vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine bonne soirée